this is one of 10 chess moves that you
have to play in your lifetime any good
chess tactics book has one pattern in it
that feels like it is only completely
different level than all of the other
tactical patterns bearing the Vivid and
accurate moniker the windmill this
pattern features an amazing sequence of
repeated discovered checks that can be
used to win a nearly unlimited amount of
material the most famous windmill is
definitely the one played by Mexican
Prodigy Carlos Torre against former
world champion Emmanuel Lasker but Bobby
Fischer's game of the century also
features a windmill here's another one
that I really like white starts with a
rook sacrifice that leads to a
combination of Bishop and Rook checks
that simply consume Black's forces